it looked like it was finally the end
this month-long campaign to keep me as
the number one subscriber to keep me
afloat above the inevitable T series a
sub gap was less than 15,000 yesterday
as closer than it's ever been
it looked like all hope was lost it
looked like it was finally a but then
something happened markiplier and
jacksepticeye finally showed up in the
final hour the last second I literally
won't shut up until you subscribe to PD
by my friends who have previously been
silent for a mysterious unknown reasons
finally decided to extend their helping
hand god bless you both so yesterday we
hit 500 500 hundred thousand subscribers
that's right I definitely deserve this
thank you very much
he thought that was it T series I bet I
bet you they were sitting there with the
champagne ready to finally pop the
bottle oh jeez doesn't have been
obnoxious oh Jesus we're not way longer
than he should have
not so fast e series I don't think so it
was a ton of other creators I show their
support as well and I seeing it all it's
just been amazing all the fans support
all the means I absolutely love it I
know I said and I still mean it I don't
care if t series passes me but this is
all too fun I don't remember the last
time I had this much fun on YouTube it
just everything has been insane it all
started with mr. beast creating the
billboards to tell people to subscribe
to me hey uh what is this one second
original content which then inspired my
fans all across the world to do the same
hand out flyers put up posters justin
roberts bought the biggest billboard in
New York City there oh my god
we did it by the beauty fight right now
guys
Davi 504 played lasagna for ten
hours straight
[Music]
package arrived hacked 550 thousand
printers to tell people to subscribe to
PewDiePie definitely a worthy cause the
amount of attention this is getting is
absolutely insane everyone seems so
caught up everyone seems so invested to
this subscribe to PewDiePie blah blah
blah and I honestly feel like I don't
deserve it I feel really weird about it
but it's a blast nonetheless you've
probably seen these live streams where
it's PewDiePie vs. t-series and everyone
is just so invested into this but
there's a part of this that I really
really don't like but and it's a shame
because I it is a vast majority of
people but it's sometimes in these
comments and you guys have told me this
as well you see comments such as like
Indians or me and c-word just
really distasteful unnecessary comments
and I obviously made Indian jokes and
stuff like that but I do that of all
countries and this is not what I'm about
and I know my fan base isn't about this
either I'm getting more attention now
that I'll probably ever get and I feel
really weird about it as well so why not
just take that fact and redirect it to
something more positive and show that
this fan base and this group of people
can do something positive as well
because I know we can no more India
let's instead help India maybe you
already knew this or maybe you didn't
but there's over 10 million child
labourers in India between the age of 5
and 14 and even more between the age of
15 and 18 almost 23 million that means
that almost 1 out of 10 kids in India
are working now this is mostly in rural
areas but this means that a lot of kids
in India are missing out a chance for a
proper education and a chance for a
proper future that's why I decided to
create a fund raiser for the charity
called crying cries a charity that
focuses on making a better future for
kids in India the reason I picked cry as
a charity is because they recognize that
just rescuing these kids won't be enough
so they instead work on identifying the
root causes for these issues to solve
them children for example work mainly to
help their families and because there's
a high demand
child labor with Christ setup strategies
to prevent these issues and uproot them
to build a better future for all of
India I think it's a great cause I would
highly encourage you to donate
I created a fund raiser down in the
description please do check it out and
donate any bit we'll help I will of
course donate as well on tomorrow
between 4 p.m. and 7 p.m. UK time I will
be live-streaming where all the proceeds
will go towards raising funds for this
charity let's do something cool I think
we can turn this around and make it
something really cool and really
positive let's actually help 9 year old
kids in India that's it thank you for
listening